n'aura pas de monsieur da monsieur
monsieur que je pas comme en
même temps le ce que première dame et je
suis célibataire premier run je vais pas
aller me trouver un mari au motif qu'il
faudrait entrer à l'elysée avec un mari
se trouve juste étonnant que ça étonne
en 2022 en france qu'une femme
célibataire soit suspecté peut-être
d'être moins performante qu'elle n'est
pas accompagnée d'un mari ça va bien
merci
[Musique]
voir
salle
[Musique]
au bras de natalia les cheveux longs et
doré olivier 50 ans espère trouver
l'amour si le french choisi
cet ingénieur dans le btp a fait appel à
une agence matrimoniale qui organise des
rencontres entre femmes ukrainiennes et
en français accompagné de la directrice
de l' agence qui traduit olivier dîne
avec natalia pour la deuxième fois j'ai
rencontré il ya deux jours elle venait
d'arriver à marseille elle débarque dans
un pays qu'elle connaît pas où elle
connaît personne et je pense que c'est
assez difficile pour elle habituellement
le village est plutôt calme mais
aujourd'hui c'est un jour particulier
il y à une cérémonie de divorce
tout le village est venu pour y
participer
cérémonie du divorce ont fait la fête
pour un divorce
c'est une tradition ici
quand une femme divorce ses amis et sa
famille se réunisse pour faire la fête
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
lagence par laquelle est passée olivier
a fait face à une explosion de demandes
messieurs qui m'a appelé trois fois des
hommes aux propositions parfois
insistante et déplacé une avalanche
d'appels mais malheureusement 90% de ces
appels ne sont pas sérieux c'est à dire
que ce sont les hommes qui espère par
mois la radio avoir la chance d'héberger
une très belle créature premium en
détresse j'ai compris
ah oui tu dois avoir les boules accepte
ou un fouet ça fait vraiment une paire
de
une paire de belles paires l'air par
rapport à l'est hormis vous qui a fait
l'amer qui a fait une bonne campagne qui
a fait la meilleure campagne hormis vous
jambes au foot et c'est à vous de faire
les commentaires mais on n'est pas
nombreux les lisent comme vous on passe
pas notre vie on regarde et on regarde
ce qu'on a à faire moi j'ai une tâche
est gelée accompli allez on va faire
l'analyse du feu donne moi ta mère
[Musique]
ça signifie l'année est anodin dr dans
le désert de jordanie l'occasion de
faire la connaissance du chargé d'audit
des comptes de la fifa voici son nom ça
ne s'invente pas de
temps x martin journaliste
au
[Rires]
delà si ça mais attendez la suite damien
jean lassalle vous avez dit à quelques
jours je vous citez pardon amis
téléspectateurs pour le langage familier
mais ce sont vos mots vous avez dit
c'est une campagne de merde c'est pas
excessif non vous ne pensez vraiment oui